well members of president Trump's
administration have been accused of all
manner of things from domestic abuse to
spying for the Russians but here's an
amazing one interior secretary Ryan's
inky former seal accused of the worst
sin of all not loving diversity enough a
breaking report this week by CNN
accusing key of seeking to hire the best
people for jobs at the Interior
Department without regard to their
appearance that was the chyron jinke
angers by hiring the best very offensive
the report was denied of course by sinky
but the Left still reacted with horror
Kristin Clarke is president and
executive director of the lawyers
Committee for civil rights under law and
she joins us now Christiane thanks for
coming on thanks for having me so I know
I can't speak for anyone else but when I
saw that CNN report that Ryan Zinke was
daring to hire the best people I thought
what is this country coming to you know
hiring people on the basis of relevant
criteria like experience or skill
commitment I mean that's just wrong and
I think you would agree with that
no we want people who are qualified and
experienced especially at the helm of
our nation's most important federal
agencies but we also need to make sure
that those agencies reflect the growing
diversity of our country and I'm not
just talking about racial diversity I'm
talking about gender diversity and
ethnic diversity and at every turn with
this administration we've seen efforts
to turn the clock back
we know that diversity is not a priority
for this administration whether we're
talking about cabinet level appointments
or judicial appointments this
administration is one that has not
placed a premium on diversity what do
you think of the NFL well they like the
NFL that's a totally different context
it is I didn't have an understatment
Civic to the same standards apply there
I mean why do they get a pass from that
no this isn't real question why are they
gonna pass on the diversity thing in the
NFL is there a reason well when we look
at the coaching ranks there's a lot of
work to do not a clear no no no sort of
maybe the represented great I'm on your
side but but the players it's all male
its disproportionately african-american
does that bother you the NFL is a sport
so
not Sam ale sport so I'm not surprised
that it's all-male but does it bother
you why do they get a pass from the
normals okay because their point is like
we hired the best and actually I think
the NFL really doesn't care what color
you are I mean they just want the best
players and is that offensive when you
watch it are you thinking I can't watch
this they're not following the diversity
rules what really bothers me it's my
taxpayer dollars your taxpayer dollars
going to support federal agencies that
don't reflect the diversity of our
country Tucker I what about you fly on
an airplane I mean do you think that
Airlines should apply the same diversity
rules you're calling for it here that
they shouldn't take the people who score
the highest on the pilot tests but that
they should hire also on appearance the
way people look every workplace whether
you're talking with your pilots to watch
those two agencies should hire the best
but should place the premium on
diversity and but which is really the
way that you look or what you do what
you're capable of doing so like when
you're flying a plane how important is
it what you look like you're incredibly
important and it's all services that we
have working it's also important that we
place a premium on diversity and the
fact that we have diversity means
appearance it means what you look like
we're talking about the shallowest
possible criterion it's it's your it's
your literally your shade that's what
you're saying well why is that more
important than Talent you know what
matters Tucker what matters is that
you're white daughters and that my black
son can turn on that TV and see an
administration that reflects the
diversity of our country gender
diversity racial diversity adversity
know what matters that means is Agustin
is run by competent people and if
they're all Pacific Islanders I don't
care where they're from I don't care
what they look like is I don't think
that what you look like is the most
important thing cuz I'm not shallow
president Trump well you're arguing that
it is I'm from a point T's have been
virtually all white and all male and we
haven't seen anything this remarkable
since the Reagan years
I mean you're just not getting anywhere
with me because if you can argue that
one of them is doing a bad job I'll
agree with you and not actually I think
some of them are not that impressive
I'll be completely blunt with you but it
has nothing to do with with what they
look like because again I'm not a
shallow person I don't judge people on
their appearance just as I don't judge
books on their cover
I try to get a little deeper than that
and I'm wondering why is this society
we've decided the shallowest possible
measure is the most important do you
ever stop and ask yourself that
diversity is one among a number of
factors taking into account when it
appoints cabinet-level positions all the
way down we want a federal government
that reflects the diversity of our but I
wonder but especially you did I just
what are you totally clear if you mean
like diversity of skills I'm totally
with you but when you're a little did
you ever think you'd be arguing to judge
people primarily on how they look you
know I'm talking about gender diversity
I'm talking about racial diversity
Tucker okay
Trump's judicial nominee aids have been
white male
not because he knows nothing about how
federal courts operate that's a problem
look I'm with you there you should ever
hire incompetent people I don't care
what they look like no one competent
people I'm with you Kristen thank you
thanks for having to see it